[ __ ] you Michael Moore I refuse to call
you an officer or cheat because you
don't desert those titles you are a
disgrace
suck my dick and choke on it I yield by
time I yield my time
suck my dick and choke on it I yield my
time and [ __ ] you so technically he oh
he went overtime that's like high level
that's high level a debate kid [ __ ] talk
but I yield my time but he gets a last
word after yeah yeah I yield my time
[ __ ] you you just said that on my time
but they didn't even look look at their
all their faces son face oh there's one
of them yeah they don't they don't they
just have it on mute completely they
just don't care
they'd it's just zero empathy not
apparently this one for nine hours
Oh speed run through all citizens
opinions and every single dude Tony Hawk
joined it yeah do you see that yeah wait
Tony Hawk's yeah bro I liked it today
we're doing a speed run on citizen
opinions tool-assisted we will be
fast-forwarding everything they have to
say my thing was they should have known
better than to get on voice chat with
pissed-off white dudes because if
there's one place pissed-off white guys
excel its voice chat yeah yeah you know
played enough games got it or bid that
yeah god forbid they didn't [ __ ] to
use discord for this I yield my time
[ __ ] you my dick and choke on it
I asked to hear that again you my time
[ __ ] you
it's sounds like a papa road song suck
my dick and choke on it I yield my time
[ __ ] you you like my biscuit dude yeah
yeah
oh my god it's fred durst man suck my
dick and choke on it somewhat dude if
someone has to do that oh my god could
make like a [ __ ] early 2001 bill up
with you this is bigger than some bad
cops our protests you've lost faith in
the people I'll see us to serve in
leadership you have lost control of your
police force and your authority's
illegitimate commissioners if you're
concerned all with the safety that
people Los Angeles if this man has not
resigned you must remove them the
situation what can you get worse until
he is gone history will judge you by the
soon as you make today I yield my time
wow isn't it isn't that wild dude we'll
see uh would have been awesome if at the
end of that he said suck my dick and
choke on it I yield my time [ __ ] you
Tony Hawk dude yeah most like composed
nicest dude ever like suck my dick use
my time [ __ ] you [ __ ] you yeah that's
all he says yield my time also [ __ ]
face yeah all right we're gonna mute go
[ __ ] yourself also good yo that lady I
have to give her props for telling
everyone thank you for 9 hours straight
yeah [ __ ] yourself thank you so much for
your tea so much next up we have we have
Jasper yeah hello can you hear me yeah
suck my [ __ ] dick
thank you so much next up we have Corey
hello is this on hi hello hi yep all
right okay thank you so much Commission
what has transpired after these events
is absolutely disgusting I would love
nothing more than to shove my fat
[ __ ] dick down your [ __ ] throats
[ __ ] you
I yield my time and go [ __ ] yourself
okay great thank you
next up Steven dude I want a guy to go
in there
next up Steven it's two minutes long
it's a ten minute long
[ __ ] you I yield my time
so my dick [ __ ] you suck my dick in it
ah [ __ ] yourself bruh just go in there
and you might come in with the auto-tune
whether someone is to come in with the
auto-tune oh yeah [ __ ] you I don't even
hear it
god damn dude [ __ ] oh well that's the
thing I love dude is I know in a time
like this you need civilized discourse
you need you know you need level heads
in the mix but goddamn it it feels so
good to hear someone just get in front
of these people and say it you know what
I'm saying oh yeah oh yeah it's always
so [ __ ] cathartic to just hear
someone finally get the chance to be
like me [ __ ] a suck a fat one different
for nine out yes I'm sure there were
people that watch this entire stream
yeah it's [ __ ] oh yeah it meant like
you think about like council meetings
and some like local council meetings and
[ __ ] like that yeah like oh my god if
they were all over zoom they'd be
[ __ ] awesome yeah everyone yeah half
the thing is people don't just go to
this [ __ ] you know saying no it's true
to get there or they don't they don't
post where it is and all that [ __ ]
that's a great point you know they're
always don't even over it it's always at
three o'clock on Tuesday in downtown
yeah everyone's like I can't I'm working
man I can't go to that [ __ ] it's a
journey
hey we should remake always we should
remake Oregon Trail but it's just trying
to get Aaron's done in in Normal LA
traffic
oh you [ __ ] your pants on the 405
restart game do you see Rob Whitman's
tweet in response to these zooms well I
would quit I would quit a job that was
just getting late in a chocolate factory
if everyone hated me so true just quit
just quit
[Laughter]
you